[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend die
Ukrainer feiern den Untergang Moskau so
heißt ja das russische Kriegsschiff dass
die Ukraine nach eigenen Angaben letzte
Nacht versenkt oder zumindest schwer
getroffen hat die russische Seite
hingegen spricht nur davon dass an Bord
Munition explodiert sei was ein
Eingeständnis von groben Fehlern der
Besatzung wäre aber offenbar immer noch
besser als zugeben zu müssen dass man
abgeschossen wurde die Moskwa ist nicht
irgendein Schiff sie ist oder war der
Stolz der russischen Marine hinzu kommt
das um die Moskwa bereits eine andere
ukrainische Heldengeschichte rankt sie
soll jenes Schiff sein das in den ersten
Kriegstagen eine vorgelagerte Insel
ansteuerte und die dort stationierten
ukrainischen Soldaten aufforderte sich
zu ergeben deren kolportierte Antwort
ging um die Welt
zwischen worship go [ __ ] yourself
Christian Kirsch berichtet
sie graben sich ein und erwarten den
russischen Ansturm ukrainische Soldaten
nordwestlich Mariupol Regen und Schlamm
aber die Moral der Kämpfer scheint
intakt
wir werden dafür sorgen dass das hier
nicht wird wie in Mariupol wir halten
stand
an einer anderen Front vermeldet das
ukrainische Militär heute einen
bedeutsamen Erfolg der russische
raketenkreuzer Moskwa hier
Archivaufnahmen bei einem Seemanöver im
Schwarzen Meer vor einem Jahr soll sagt
die Ukraine bei einem ukrainischen
Angriff schwer beschädigt worden sein
im Operationsgebiet wurde das
Flaggschiff Moskwa von einer
anti-schiffsrakete getroffen und schwer
beschädigt ein Feuer ist ausgebrochen
andere Schiffe wollten helfen aber die
starken Explosionen der Munition haben
den Kreuzer gekippt und er beginnt zu
sinken
die Ukraine hieß es aber das Schiff mit
der selbst entwickelten
anti-schiffsrakete Neptun angegriffen
der Angriff wurde offenbar unterstützt
durch die in der Türkei entwickelte
kampfdrohne beiracta die für zahlreiche
militärische Erfolge der Ukraine
verantwortlich gemacht wird die Drohne
hier präsentiert bei einer Militärparade
in Kiew belegt den hohen technischen
Standard vieler ukrainischer
Waffensysteme Russland dementierte dass
der Kreuzer gesunken sei von einem
großen Brand war die Rede die Besatzung
habe das Schiff verlassen man plane die
Moskva abzuschleppen auf die Krim
sollte die maska sinken ist das
Flaggschiff der Schwarzmeerflotte für
Russlands Marine nicht zu ersetzen denn
die Zufahrt zum Schwarzen Meer der
Bosporus bleibt vom NATO-Mitglied Türkei
für russische Kriegsschiffe gesperrt die
masqua von hoher Symbolkraft hat es
schon bis auf eine ukrainische
Briefmarke geschafft die den Widerstand
ukrainischer Soldaten gegen die
russische marinewürdigt auf der
Schlangeninsel nahe Odessa
unterdessen weitere zum Teil wahllose
Raketenangriffe der russischen Armee wie
hier auf einen städtischen
Vergnügungspark in rakif
im noch umkämpften mariopol bleiben
Trümmer zurück wo Russlands Armee ein
marschierte irgendwo mittendrin sitzt
Valentina plettnio war
warum zerstören Sie uns warum
13-stöckige Häuser sind hier ausgebrannt
die Menschen sitzen im Keller ohne
Toilette eines der Häuser ist jetzt
eingestürzt und 19 Menschen sind tot
weite Teile der Hafenstadt sind
inzwischen und der russischer Kontrolle
doch es gibt noch immer ukrainischen
Widerstand
Tim Krüger ist für uns in Kiew timben es
stimmt dass dieses Schiff schwer
beschädigt ist also außer Gefecht was
könnte das für die kriegsszenerie dort
unten an der Küste bedeuten
also wenn es wirklich so ist dass dieser
raketenkreuzer Maus quasi so schwer
beschädigt ist dass er in diesem Krieg
nicht mehr eingreifen kann dann denke
ich wäre das ein erheblicher Schlag für
die russischen Streitkräfte denn die
Kampfhandlungen verlagern sich ja jetzt
immer mehr die konzentrieren sich auf
den Osten und den Südosten des Landes
also auch in Küstenregionen und die
moskau ist ein Schiff das durchaus über
einer erhebliche Feuerkraft verfügt und
diese stünde dann eben nicht mehr zur
Verfügung das ist übrigens auch die
Einschätzung des nationalen
Sicherheitsberaters der USA Sullivan der
sagt der Verlust dieses Schiffes also
wenn dieses Schiff tatsächlich nicht
mehr eingesetzt werden könnte dann wäre
das ein schwerer Dämpfer für Russland
in den nächsten Tagen eine Großoffensive
vor allem im Osten
genauso ist es nach ukrainischen Angaben
scheint es auch so zu sein dass die
Vorbereitung für eine solche Offensive
bereits weitgehend abgeschlossen sind
also man geht hier in der Ukraine ganz
offenbar davon aus dass der Angriff also
ein größerer Angriff unmittelbar
bevorsteht der ukrainische Präsident
selenski sagt dass die russischen
Streitkräfte Zehntausende von Soldaten
in dieser Region zusammenziehen und
selensky hat in den vergangenen Wochen
oder viel mehr Tagen immer wieder
massiver dieser Offensive gewarnt er hat
vor allem Waffenlieferungen eingefordert
vor allem das Liefern von schweren
Waffen auch von Deutschland damit eben
die Ukraine in die Lage versetzt wird
sich gegen diese Offensive zu werden im
Moment geht es vor allem darum noch so
viele Menschen wie möglich aus diesen
potenziellen Kampfzonen herauszuholen
also die zu evakuieren und ukrainische
offizielle sagen dass diese Schlacht um
dem Donbass womöglich an den Zweiten
Weltkrieg erinnern könnte ganze Städte
könnten zerstört werden und die
ukrainische Seite hat massive Gegenwehr
angekündigt es könnte also sein dass
dieser Krieg der ja ohnehin schon seit
Wochen so unerbittlich geführt wird dass
der noch mal dann eine neue Phase
eintritt und zwar in eine wesentlich
brutalere und härtere Phase danke schön
Tim nach Kiew ja in der Tat die Ukraine
bittet vor allem um schwere Waffen um
sich nämlich nicht nur zu verteidigen
sondern die Russen auch zurückdrängen zu
können dafür genügen Gewehre
Panzerfäuste oder Geländewagen nicht
dafür braucht es schweres Gerät also
Panzer Flugzeuge Kriegsschiffe
großkalibrige Flugabwehrsysteme mehrere
Länder liefern das auch bereits die USA
haben gerade eine neue 800 Millionen
dollar-liste veröffentlicht auf der
schwere Waffen stehen estland hat
Haubitzen geliefert also schwere
Artilleriegeschütze Polen und Tschechien
haben Panzer geschickt die Slowakei ist
bereit Mic Kampfjets zu liefern
derweil geht in Deutschland die
politische Debatte weiter wie Thomas
reicher berichtet
in einer Halle in Flensburg steht viel
von dem was die Ukraine im Krieg gegen
Russland gerne hätte von der
Bundesregierung aber bislang nicht bekam
eng geparkt rund 100 Leopard 1
Kampfpanzer außerdem 60 Panzer Mörser
M113 sowie Brücken und pionierpanzer von
der Bundeswehr ausgemustert aber noch
gut verwendbar für die Ukraine
wir haben sowieso auch Bedarf an den
bergepanzern die Sie gerade hinter mir
sehen aber auch an den Leopard 1 die
hier auch vor Ort sind in Flensburg und
zur Verfügung stellen könnten die in
wenigen Wochen das Panzer Lager in
Flensburg gehört der Firma FFG die
spezialisiert darauf ist altes Gerät
wiederherzurichten kurz nach Putins
Angriff batters Verteidigungsministerium
auch die FFG um eine Liste was sie der
Ukraine liefern könnten die fertige
Liste ging nach Berlin ans Ministerium
Anfang März war das seitdem hat die FFG
nichts mehr gehört trotz der Hilferufe
aus Kiew herrscht Schweigen in Berlin
der Bundeskanzler hat ja gesagt dass er
sowohl die Bundeswehr modernisieren will
aber eben auch die Ukraine unterstützen
das muss dann jetzt konsequent umgesetzt
werden das darf auch nicht in der
Verwaltung dann wochenlang dauern denn
der Krieg geht weiter wir müssen hier
schneller werden und auch die
Bundesregierung muss hier schnell zu
Entscheidungen kommen in Berlin wächst
so die Kritik an Kanzler Scholz der
Druck wie andre starten auch schwere
Waffen zu liefern das liegt im
Bundeskanzleramt Olaf Scholz steht auf
der Bremse er will das ganz
offensichtlich nicht und er lädt damit
eine große Verantwortung auf sich seine
Belastung für Deutschland insgesamt er
hilft der Ukraine nicht so wie es
möglich wäre die Kritik kommt längst
auch aus den Reihen der Ampel von
Abgeordneten etwa die kürzlich selbst in
die Ukraine reisten mit verzweifelten
Parlamentariern dort Sprachen und wie
der Listen bekamen was die Ukraine alles
brauche Waffen zum Beispiel wie sie in
Flensburg stehen doch wie zerrissen
insbesondere die SPD in der Frage ist
zeigt sich heute die Abgeordneten
Delegation wird abgekanzelt vom
Fraktionsvorsitzenden sich vor Ort ein
Bild zu machen kann richtig sein unter
diesem Eindruck allerdings bisher
beispiellose Entscheidungen zu fordern
ohne sie selbst verantworten zu müssen
ist falsch zumal diese weitgehende
Konsequenzen für die Sicherheit unseres
Landes und der NATO haben könnten
doch FDP grüne und Teile der SPD drängen
weiter auf eine Kursänderung jedenfalls
dann wenn noch mehr NATO starten
mitmachen es gibt bisher zwei Länder die
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge geliefert haben das
in Polen und Tschechien und zwar
russischer Bauart alle anderen
NATO-Staaten haben das nicht getan wenn
es eine Veränderung der Linie gibt muss
sie gemeinsam und geschlossen erfolgen
vor der russischen Botschaft legen
ukrainische Flüchtlinge heute Babypuppen
auf dem Boden fordern rettet unsere
Kinder eine Anklage gegenüber Russland
und ein Hilferuf an Deutschland
tja und noch ein aktueller Nachtrag
jetzt eben in diesem Moment kann meine
Meldung der Nachrichtenagentur Reuters
dem entstehen nach hat der russische
Verteidigungsminister gesagt dass die
moskw also das Kriegsschiff gesunken
sein das entsprechend an dem was die
Ukraine ja von Anfang an schon gesagt
haben aber es ist im Moment wie gesagt
nur eine Quelle da muss man noch ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein
direkt nach Amtsantritt mit einem
solchen Krieg konfrontiert zu werden das
wünscht man jedenfalls keiner Regierung
den Grünen hat das bislang aber nicht
geschadet im Gegenteil Robert Habeck und
Annalena baerbock haben an Popularität
kräftig zugelegt anders als SPD und FDP
mussten sie ja auch keine politischen
kehrtwänden in der Einschätzung von
Russland oder Nord Stream 2 vollführen
und obwohl Habeck als
Wirtschaftsminister in Kriegszeiten
jetzt plötzlich Dinge tun muss die ein
grüner eigentlich nicht will ist er zum
beliebtesten deutschen Politiker
aufgestiegen
so gesehen lief es für die Grünen seit
Amtsantritt also eigentlich sehr gut bis
das Debakel um Familienministerin Anne
Spiegel kam ihrem Nachfolgerin soll das
jetzt schnell vergessen machen mattes
Feldhoff stellt sie vor
sie war die große Überraschung die die
keiner auf dem Zettel hatte aber bei
ihrer Vorstellung hinterlässt Lisa Paus
am Nachmittag den Eindruck dass sie
eigentlich so etwas wie die natürliche
Wahl ist natürlich musste ich erstmal
darüber nachdenken
das war jetzt erstmal nicht mein Plan ja
aber ich habe dann kurz darüber
nachgedacht und habe dann festgestellt
ganz ehrlich ich bin zu den Grünen
gekommen weil ich Feministin bin ich
habe aus tiefster Überzeugung mit sehr
sehr viel Engagement dafür gekämpft dass
sie Kinder Grundsicherung ein
Kernbestandteil grüner sozial und
Kinderpolitik ist als eine der
ArchitektInnen dieser
Kindergrundsicherung soll die gelernte
finanzpolitikerin eine erfahrene
Parlamentarierin die seit 2009 im
Bundestag sitzt jetzt das Frauen und
Familienministerium führen ein
Ministerium das den Grünen besonders
wichtig ist
wir wissen wie groß die
Herausforderungen die Aufgaben in dieser
Zeit sind es ist das zentrale
Ministerium für Gesellschaftspolitik
über das wir sprechen Lisa Pausch
scheint perfekt in das
Anforderungsprofil der Grünen zu passen
Frau vom linken Flügel und kompetent so
hat es der Bundesvorstand formuliert und
sie unterscheidet sich von ihrer
Vorgängerin eine Spiegel denn Pauls
kennt das Berliner Parkett und seine
Härte
sie bringt Leidenschaft mit insbesondere
für soziale Themen für Kinderarmut für
Seniorinnen und Senioren für die
Menschen in diesem Land und genau danach
haben wir entschieden ob auch Olaf
Scholz so erfreut ist über die Wahl mit
der wohl für sich behalten jedenfalls
sind seine Erinnerungen an die letzte
Begegnung mit dieser Pausch vor dem
Wirecard Untersuchungsausschuss nicht
ganz so ungetrübt noch vor einem halben
Jahr war Pauls der Meinung Scholz sein
als Finanzminister überfordert
steht eben nach wie vor im Raum dass die
Behörde falsch gearbeitet hat klar ist
dass Olaf Scholz seine Behörden nicht im
Griff hat jetzt wo Scholz nicht nur Chef
der Finanzbehörden ist sondern sogar
Chef der ganzen Regierung wollen das
beide lieber wieder vergessen jetzt
freue ich mich auf die konstruktive und
erfolgreiche Zusammenarbeit ich habe
auch bereits mit ihm telefoniert und ich
kann sagen wir freuen uns beide Lisa
Paus muss jetzt die größte Krise der
Grünen seit regierungsbeginn im letzten
Jahr vergessen machen eine Krise die an
den Grundfragen kratzte dem Vertrauen
und der Solidität von Politik
und jetzt erstmal die Nachrichten von
Heinz Wolf erneut sorgt in den USA ein
Polizeieinsatz für Empörung bei dem ein
junger Schwarzer ums Leben gekommen ist
die Polizei von Grand Rapids in Michigan
hat jetzt Videos von dem Vorfall von vor
zehn Tagen veröffentlicht demnach kommt
es nach einer aus dem Ruder gelaufenen
Verkehrskontrolle zu einer
Auseinandersetzung in deren Verlauf der
Polizist dem Mann in den Kopf schießt
laut Polizei läuft die Untersuchung noch
der Polizist sei derzeit beurlaubt
der britische Premierminister Johnson
treibt trotz scharfer Kritik von
Bürgerrechtlern und der Opposition seine
Pläne voran Migranten für die Dauer
ihres Asylantrags nach Ruanda
auszufliegen mit dem ostafrikanischen
Land sei eine entsprechende Vereinbarung
getroffen worden sagte Johnson damit
versucht die Regierung nach eigenen
Angaben Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge von der
gefährlichen und illegalen Überfahrt
über den Ärmelkanal abzuschrecken und
Menschenhändlern das Handwerk zu legen
in Südafrika dauert die Suche nach
Überlebenden nach den verheerenden
Überschwemmungen an die Zahl der
Todesopfer ist auf mehr als 300
gestiegen dutzende weitere Menschen
werden immer noch vermisst viele
Gegenden sind ohne Strom und fließendes
Wasser ungewöhnlich heftige Regenfälle
hatten vor allem im Großraum Durban
schwere Überflutungen und Erdrutsche
ausgelöst
dass es sich bei der sogenannten
querdenker-szene nicht nur um harmlose
Zeitgenossen mit eigenwilligen Weltbild
handelt das ist schon lange offenkundig
dem Verfassungsschutz ist auch nicht
entgangen wie sich corona-leugner und
rechtsextreme Reichsbürger vermengten
spätestens beim versuchten Sturm auf den
Reichstag dürfte dem letzten klar
geworden sein dass ich hier Leute
versammelten denen es keineswegs nur
darum ging die Notwendigkeit des Maske
Tragens in Frage zu stellen in mehreren
Bundesländern gab es umfängliche Razzien
und eine Gruppe Männer und Frauen wurde
festgenommen sie sollen
Sprengstoffanschläge die Entführung des
Bundesgesundheitsministers und den Sturz
der Regierung geplant haben Susanne
gehlhardt und Christopher Heinze
berichten
es waren keine Spinner am Berg sondern
gefährliche Kriminelle die sogenannte
chatgruppe vereinte Patrioten plante
Stromausfälle durch Sprengstoffanschläge
um mit Chaos und bürgerkriegsähnlichen
Zuständen in Deutschland die Macht zu
übernehmen und die Demokratie zu
beseitigen
hier ist diese diese Schwelle in die
reale Welt überschritten worden es gab
ja ganz konkrete Pläne den
Bundesminister für Gesundheit zu
entführen und wir haben geglaubt die
Schwelle
zur Vorbereitung dieser Tat ist in dem
Moment überschritten wo es darum ging
die Waffen zu besorgen und sie auch dann
eben zu kaufen mit diesen Waffen sollte
auch der Personenschutz des
Gesundheitsministers getötet werden der
ganze Vorgang zeigt dass sich die
corona-proteste nicht nur radikalisiert
haben hier geht es also um Kräfte die
eine also Absicht haben auch den Staat
und die Demokratie zu destabilisieren
nutzen offenbar die corona-proteste
seine kleine Minderheit in der
Gesellschaft aber hochgefährlich meine
eigene Arbeit wird das nicht
beeinflussen ich werde weitermachen wie
bisher über den messenger-dienst
telegram verbreitete die Gruppe
Umsturzpläne
seit vorbereitet es kann jetzt jeden Tag
losgehen nettes Marschbefehl wenn ihr
wollt das System muss weg
weder Herr Lauterbach noch wir lassen
uns als Demokratin Demokraten davon
einschüchtern wir werden nach wie vor
hart daran arbeiten die Demokratie zu
schützen es hat jetzt noch mal gezeigt
dass solche hasskommentare das inchats
bei telegram solche Äußerungen getätigt
werden das rechtfertigt aus meiner Sicht
des harte Vorgehen gegen diese Plattform
bei Razzien in neuen Bundesländern
wurden gestern vier Personen
festgenommen insgesamt wird gegen 12
ermittelt die Hauptverdächtigen ein
55-jähriger aus Neustadt an der
Weinstraße und ein 54-jähriger aus
Falkensee bei Berlin
insgesamt ist es aus meiner Sicht
bedeutsam dass wir es hier mit einer
Melange zu tun haben
bestehende aus
Verschwörungstheoretikern Impfgegnern
aber auch
reichsbürgern die wir eigentlich in
dieser Form bisher nicht festgestellt
hatten es Feind mit dieser Gruppen ist
tatsächlich von einer gemeinsam
geteilten paranoiden Vorstellungen
geprägt die im Grunde besagt die da oben
und auch große Teile der Bevölkerung
dadurch dass sie mitmachen in der
Gesellschaft im System sind eigentlich
Teil des Problems sind das Problem dass
es zu überwinden gibt den
Ermittlungsteams in Mainz und dem
Bundesgebiet ist heute ein wichtiger
Schlag gelungen gegen eine neue Art von
Bedrohung die alle treffen kann
und noch schnell eine Aktualisierung
auch die dpa meldet jetzt mit Berufung
auf die russische Nachrichtenagentur
Tast die russische Regierung bestätigt
ihr Kriegsschiff Moskva ist gesunken die
Ukraine würden sagen es wurde versenkt
Tim Wechsel nicht nur Ökonomen haben
heute mit Spannung nach Frankfurt
geblickt wird die EZB die Europäische
Zentralbank die Leitzinsen anheben
Spoiler nein das tat sie nicht sie
bleibt erstmal weiter bei ihrer
Nullzinspolitik viele hatten auf einer
Zinserhöhung gehofft und sie auch
gefordert immerhin haben wir im Euroraum
inzwischen eine Inflationsrate von
siebeneinhalb Prozent allerdings stehen
die europäischen Währungshüter vor einem
heiklen Problem die aktuelle Inflation
wird von Preisanstiegen auf der
güterseite getrieben also auf der
Angebotsseite etwa durch teures Öl und
Gas dagegen kann die EZB über ihre
Geldpolitik nicht viel tun das macht die
Sache nicht einfacher für die Notenbank
nicht und auch nicht für die Wirtschaft
Peter Wagner
Christian kirchhübl ist verantwortlich
für 630 Mitarbeitenden aller Welt 450
davon in Wetzlar dort produziert der
Familienbetrieb Oculus seit 125 Jahren
vor allem Präzisionsinstrumente für
Ärzte und Optiker bester Deutscher
Mittelstand Umsatz deutlich über 100
Millionen Euro im Jahr die hohe
Inflation macht dem Chef sorgen
unternehmerische Entscheidungen werden
schwierig das Preisniveau stabil ist
dann können wir berechenbar
Investitionen planen wenn das
Preisniveau nicht stabil ist das ist so
wie wenn sie Fahrrad fahren und haben
eine Augenbinde auf die Preise kennen
nur eine Richtung Kraftstoffe im
Jahresvergleich plus 50% Gas +42 wer
frisches Gemüse sucht zahlt 15% mehr
insgesamt steigt die Inflationsrate im
März auf
7,3%. höchster Stand seit 1990 stabile
Preise sehen anders aus
Preisstabilität ist die wichtigste
Aufgabe der Europäischen Zentralbank
doch die EZB heizt das inflationsfeuer
durch Staatsanleihenkäufe noch an
gzb hat ein Problem und das Problem ist
dass sie die Inflation viel zu lange
ignoriert hat und sich nur darauf
konzentriert hat die Zinsen niedrig zu
halten und die Finanzierungsbedingungen
für alle europäischen Länder günstig zu
machen und jetzt ist das Kind in den
Brunnen gefallen das Kind wird auch noch
eine Weile im Brunnen bleiben keine
Überraschungen heute bei der EZB
Präsidentin Lagarde zur Zeit Corona
positiv macht die Pressekonferenz aus
dem Homeoffice im dritten Quartal könnte
sich die Geldpolitik endlich ändern
deutet sie vorsichtig an journey hat die
Reise hat also bereits begonnen und sie
geht weiter wie vorhergesagt im
Durchschnitt 7,5% Inflation ist deutlich
zu hoch
die EZB ist in der Zwickmühle durch den
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine sind
Rohstoffpreise weltweit massiv gestiegen
die lockdowns in Shanghai und anderswo
in China gefährden aufs Neue die
internationalen Lieferketten erhöht die
Bank die Zinsen um die Inflation zu
senken könnte die Wirtschaft leiden
Arbeitslosigkeit drohen und für
hochverschuldete Euroländer könnte die
Staatsfinanzierung plötzlich teurer
werden
der EZB spricht in ihrer Kommunikation
immer wieder von den Finanzierungskosten
insbesondere den Finanzierungskosten der
Staaten die sind extrem niedrig die
möchte sie niedrig halten aber die
Inflation hat Priorität die muss
bekämpft werden da muss man die Zinsen
erhöhen und das können die Staaten auch
verkraften ich halte Befürchtungen dass
die Staaten das nicht verkraften können
wenn die EZB den Zinsen normalisiert für
übertrieben auch wenn die EZB demnächst
einmal die Zinswende einleiten sollte an
steigende Preise werden wir uns noch
längere Zeit gewöhnen müssen
und zur Börse und da heute mal zunächst
der Blick auf die US-Börse und die
Aktien von Tesla und Twitter wie kommt
das Angebot von Tesla Chef Elon Musk an
Sina meine New Yorker Börse wird das
mehr als skeptisch gesehen sowohl bei
der Twitter als auch bei der tesla-aktie
ist gerade die Luft raus sollte Elon
Musk mit seinen Plänen durchkommen die
Nachrichtendienst Twitter komplett zu
kaufen könnte selbst er als reichster
Mann der Welt das nicht aus der
Portokasse bezahlen er müsste Anteile
seines elektroautoherstellers Tesla
verkaufen der Wert der tesla-aktie
verliert an der New Yorker Börse heute
bisher mehr als drei Prozent erst vor
gut zwei Wochen ist Elon Musk bei
Twitter eingestiegen und mit einem
Anteil von 9,2% bereits größter
Einzelaktionär er hat mehr als 80
Millionen Follower und ist dort selbst
einer der aktivsten Nutzer ein Posten im
Verwaltungsrat lehnte er erst kürzlich
ab denn mit dieser Mitgliedschaft hätte
er seinen Anteil nicht erhöhen können
und Musk will ganz offensichtlich seine
Macht in den sozialen Medien ausbauen
twitter hat ein außergewöhnliches
Potenzial ich werde es freisetzen über
masks Übernahmepläne muss nun der
Aufsichtsrat entscheiden ein
Großaktionär hat schon angekündigt bei
dem Vorhaben nicht mitzumachen Twitter
selbst will die Pläne aufmerksam prüfen
sollte Mast mit seinem Vorstoß
erfolgreich sein will er Twitter von der
Börse nehmen weil der Dienst nur so das
Potenzial als Plattform für Redefreiheit
ausschöpfen könne sagt er
Muskelspiele auch an der Frankfurter
Börse der DAX geht leicht gestärkt ins
lange Osterwochenende Sina Mallnitz
vielen Dank
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball Europa
League RB Leipzig hat bei Atlanta Berger
Modas Viertelfinale Rückspiel mit 2:0
gewonnen und damit steht Leipzig
erstmals im Halbfinale der Europa League
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck will
die staatliche Förderung von
plug-in-hybridautos Ende 2022 streichen
laut Wirtschaftsministerium seien
plug-in-hybridautos jetzt marktgängig
und benötigten keine öffentliche
Förderung mehr Umweltverbände
kritisierten die Kaufprämie für
Plug-in-Hybride seit langem da diese vor
allem im SUV Segment angeboten und
überwiegend nicht elektrisch gefahren
werden
jetzt die Osterferien und am Horizont
winkt schon der Sommer hoffentlich mit
niedrigeren Inzidenzen irgendwann kommt
dann aber auch wieder der Herbst und da
waren schon vielen dass das corona-mäßig
wieder übel werden könnten
schlimmstenfalls sogar wieder mit
Zugangsbeschränkungen Homeoffice oder
sogar Homeschooling ob sich bis dahin
dann alle Schulen und Büros in
Deutschland digital fit gemacht haben da
darf man Zweifel haben insofern ist es
schon bemerkenswert wie die Flüchtlinge
aus der Ukraine uns gerade ihren Stand
der Digitalisierung vor Augen führen
Schulunterricht fernab der Heimat
zumindest technisch ist das kein Problem
sein
im Garten oder uns Freunde besuchen uns
Pascha ist 11 seine Familie ist aus der
zentral-ukraine geflohen 100 Kilometer
von denen umkämpften Gebieten im Osten
entfernt schon während der Flucht und
auch jetzt in der Nähe von Hamburg hat
Pascha Online-Unterricht
Mama hat dann an einem Tag gesagt dass
wir weg müssen erst nach Polen und als
wir einen halben Tag da waren nach
Deutschland die Hälfte meiner Klasse ist
da geblieben
die Lehrerinnen sind ebenfalls da
geblieben in kreoponicki sie
unterrichten von zu Hause immer wieder
müssen sie den Unterricht unterbrechen
Luftalarm
an manchen Tagen haben wir fünf Mal
Luftalarm manchmal gar nicht erzählt
Maria merdag Paschas Englischlehrerin
wir laufen dann in die Schutzbunker
konnte ich alle Stunden mit meinen
Kindern abhalten wir sind weit gekommen
dann kam doch wieder Luftalarm
macht dann im sicheren Deutschland
Hausaufgaben seine Mutter Larissa sitzt
im Rollstuhl sie konnte nicht mit in die
Luftschutzbunker auch deshalb ist die
Familie sehr früh geflohen
wir haben eine lange Flucht gehabt in
Turnhallen und Schulen geschlafen für
Pascha war das eine schlimme Zeit jetzt
ist der glücklich manche seiner
Klassenkameraden sind sogar neidisch
dass er hier im schönen Deutschland sein
kann
Nummer drei auch Tatjana jawollka ist
geflohen aus leviv sie ist Lehrerin und
wollte ihre Kinder an einem Hamburger
Gymnasium anmelden der Schulleiter nahm
sie gleich mit dazu jetzt unterrichtet
sie eine internationale
willkommensklasse auch mit ihren eigenen
Kindern
ich habe pädagogische Ausbildung und ich
kann auch helfen mit unten mit alle
ukrainische Kinder da ich sehe dass sie
brauchen das in diesem Moment so ich bin
jetzt hier am Fernunterricht aus der
Ukraine nehmen die Kinder aus ihrer
Klasse nicht mehr teil die Schule hat
ein rein ukrainisches Angebot am
Nachmittag für die Kinder eine neue
Gemeinschaft Pascha wird noch diese
Woche aus der Ukraine unterrichtet dann
wechselt auch er an eine deutsche Schule
mit guten Startvoraussetzungen erlernt
Deutsch als zweite Fremdsprache bereits
seit einem Dreivierteljahr
ich komme aus
mit lernwilligen Kindern geht es gleich
auch weiter in unserem neuen zdf-format
don't stop the music und wir beide
melden uns morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das ist der Blick
von der internationalen Raumstation auf
unserer Atmosphäre und was wir hier
sehen ist auf dem Pazifik ein wunderbar
ausgeprägtes tief was wir aber noch
sehen ist dass die Atmosphäre sehr sehr
dünn ist und diese sehr schmale Schicht
das ist der Bereich wo sich das Wetter
abspielt was uns quasi vom Weltraum
trennt und diese zehn Kilometer in dem
das Wetter geschieht das Verschmutzen
wir mit Treibhausgasen schauen wir auf
das aktuelle Wetter und da tropft das
hochfront Skandinavien allmählich weiter
nach Süden nach Deutschland und es gibt
zwei geteiltes Wetter im Westen Europas
ist es deutlich wärmer als im Osten und
das stellt sich folgendermaßen da fünf
bis zehn Grad nach Osten in 20 bis 30
Grad zum Beispiel Richtung iberische
Insel in der Nacht gibt es einzelne
Schauer nach Osten hin mehr Regen im
Süden und ja im Westen lockert es auf
bei Temperaturen von vier bis zehn Grad
morgen dann im Osten dicht bewölkt mit
etwas sprührigen es lässt aber dann
allmählich nach und auch an den
alpengips Schauer die werden auch
weniger sonst aber sonnige Abschnitte
bei höchsten Temperaturen von 8 bis 13
Grad in der Nordosthälfte und 13 bis 21
Grad in der Südwesthälfte kommenden Tage
über Ostern weiterhin sonniges Wetter im
Osten eher kühler als im Westen bei 9
bis 18 Grad am Samstag und Ostermontag
10 bis 19 Grad ein schönen Abend